but i just
even if they did kick me off the [ __ ]
thing still my case
you know what it's like when the case
gets inside you like that
it's not a switch you can just turn off
i didn't solve that case
what the girl from upper darby
her parents hired a p.i because we
weren't working fast enough
some [ __ ] drunk ex-cop gonna make
some extra cash
calls me out of the blue one day says he
wants to compare notes i think she's got
some
i ignored
a couple weeks go by i'm in the area so
i dropped by his house
his sister's there packing up the place
says he's in hospice his liver gave out
if i help myself then he files
so find one mark's able
take it home son of a [ __ ] if he didn't
piece it all together
neighbor gave an alibi that didn't check
out
he caught it i missed it
i file the search warrant i hit the
perps house
find the poor girl shoe in his bedroom
guy confesses
case closed
why'd you do it i don't [ __ ] know
i think i really just wanted to do
something great
for once in my life
makes you feel any better i hid drugs on
my grandson's mother
that's why they put me on leave
are you serious
holy [ __ ]
doing something great is overrated
because people expect that from you
all the time what they don't realize is
they're just as screwed up as they are
hang on table
right bye seven matches on blue vans in
the area the night of aaron's murder
get the addresses let's go knock on some
doors
what was that for
how do you know what i want
[Music]
does that van over there belong to you
oh
yes how long have you had it well about
four years i
run my housekeeping business out of it
anyone else you work with ever drive it
that's me and my sister does that van
over there how long do you was my
husband's
your husband around he died two years
ago
what's this about anyway so am i in some
sort of
trouble or something no you're not in
any trouble mr potts we just need to get
some details from you
details about what it might be easier if
we
step inside let me just take a few
minutes
you